does MINECRAFT seem like a Nintendo game
to you it's already on the Wii U but
Shigeru Miyamoto thinks Nintendo should
have made the game in the first place
speaking of LIXIL the creator of the
mario and zelda series said his team had
tried to build something similar a few
consoles ago he stated i do like
Minecraft but really more from the
perspective of the fact that I really
feel like that's something we should
have made we had actually done a lot of
experiments that were similar to that
back in the n64 days and we had some
designs that were very similar it's
really impressive to me to see how
they've been able to take that idea and
turn it into a product speaking of
Nintendo you can check out GameSpot's
top 5 Wii U games of 2016 right now and
tune in to our game of the year live
stream on Tuesday December twentieth at
ten a.m. Pacific will have all sorts of
special guests and prizes for you there
for all the latest Nintendo news you're
already in the right place
you